[Music]
hey you guys
time for another tomes of terror where i
review
books horror books but today we have
something
a little bit different not all that
different but a little bit different
this is magpie murders
by anthony horowitz this is
a whodunit but it's actually a whodunit
with
a difference it's almost kind of like a
classic whodunit
wrapped in a modern day thriller who
done it like a turducken
of whodunit if you will but yeah this
was a really really really good book i'm
gonna just say
like right at the outset now this was a
huge bestseller came out of 2017.
uh new york times bestseller la uh
whatever the review of books bestseller
it was on like a whole bunch of like end
of year like uh best books
list npr and a bunch of other uh things
and i just
found out uh it was announced just a
couple months ago
that they're making in the uk they're
making a six
part series of this book that's gonna
air i don't know where it's gonna air
but it's gonna air somewhere in the uk
because the writer is british
now the writer of this book anthony
horowitz he's actually the guy
that did mid-summer murders uh on uk tv
and also foils war
i believe um he's also written a couple
of like sherlock holmes novels i think
it was one called moriarty
and uh there was one called i can't
remember what the other one was called
something
silk in it but i think this was actually
his first
like done it like in novel form
and um he wanted he said he wanted to do
something a little bit different with
the genre
but it's not so different that it's like
it's cool because it's kind of like
you get the best of both worlds so you
kind of get like a classic
agatha christie style murder mystery
in the middle part like as the oreo
filling and then around the outside you
have like a more contemporary
sort of murder mystery or like an
investigation kind of centered around
the publishing industry
so basically what happens in this book
you start out at the very beginning
and the book is told from the point of
view of susan ryland who is an
editor at a place called cleverleaf
books in london
and their main author is this guy named
alan conway
and alan conway has been writing these
novels
about a german investigator named
atticus
pund i guess i'm not sure how you
pronounce like the umlaut kind of thing
i'm sure i'm pronouncing that totally
wrong
but uh yeah so he's had like a really
successful series of
um whodunits like with this investigator
and they're very like agatha christie
style like old school type murder
mysteries
so at the very beginning of the book uh
they have received
alan conway's latest book
which is called magpie murders like i
said i'm not gonna spoil anything in any
of these reviews
but um i do have to like
go into some plot points that you know
just to talk about the book
so if you really don't want to know
anything about anything like about this
book other than maybe like the bearish
description
then you know maybe go read it first and
then come back and we'll talk about it a
little bit because
i don't want to like accidentally spoil
something that's going to ruin it for
people
you know what i'm saying just you know
so basically there's like a little bit
of an introduction
with susan ryland where she kind of
talks about her life she talks a little
bit about allen conway about her job and
everything like that at this publishing
company
and then pretty much the next that's
just like a few pages
and then pretty much the next 200 pages
is the bulk of the manuscript
for the mag for magpie murders which is
the book which is written by alan conway
so it's like a book within a book
now this part of the story is
a fictional tale of uh atticus
pund the investigator going to this
little town in somerset in the 1950s
investigating well there's one death
that happens there's like this old
this older lady who falls down the
stairs and even though
it looks like an accident um enough
people in town think that it might be a
murder that someone in the town like
goes
to london to like enlist his help in the
investigation
and at first he doesn't want to do it
because he doesn't really think there's
anything
for him uh you find out that atticus
pund the character
is dying because i guess alan conway
didn't want to write any more books
about him so he's killing the character
off at the end of this book this is
going to be his last one
but then it so happens that a
few days after this woman's supposedly
accidental death where she falls down
the stairs at this big manor house
the owner of the same manor house is
unquestionably murdered
and so then atticus decides that he's
gonna go
and investigate so those 200 pages like
after the
very brief introduction is pretty much
just a straightforward
old-school agatha christie style 50s
murder mystery where he's like trying to
figure out there's like all this is
really small town
there's all this kind of intrigue about
like the people that live at the manor
house and there's everybody's got
secrets and there's like you know all
these red herrings and all these
suspects
everybody has a reason for killing her
everybody has a reason for killing him
it's like
you know this big this big thing so then
you get through
about 200 pages of this and then it just
abruptly stops
now you find out that what ended up
happening was that alan conway who wrote
this book
had sent the manuscript to the publisher
but the last few chapters in which he
reveals
who the murderer was in his fictional
book are missing
so after that point we go back with
susan ryland who were introduced to at
the beginning of the book
and she's basically conducting an
investigation
well at first she's conducting an
investigation trying to find
the last few chapters of this book
because this guy this is like a smaller
publishing company
allen conway um is their best-selling
author even though no one really likes
him because he's really cranky and
difficult
but he's their best-selling author they
need this book you know to keep their uh
business afloat and they have no idea
like where these pages might have gone
now it turns out that a couple days
after the manuscript arrives at the
publisher
with supposedly the last few chapters
missing alan conway himself
turns up dead in a way that could be an
accident could be suicide
also could be murder so the editor
while she started out like looking for
the last chapters
of magpie murders this book that you
know they need to publish
she finds herself kind of getting more
sucked into
maybe this guy got murdered and so she's
um like conducting an investigation of
her own
so it's really kind of cool how the
contemporary mystery
with the publisher and the or the
publishing house and the editor
and the author of this book within a
book that he turns up dead and her like
kind of going through
an investigation but in a more
contemporary fashion
kind of sort of parallels the
the fictional story that's uh that's
been told in the manuscript
magpie murders so
this book was delightful it was just
like
it's it seems long like i guess when i
first got it i was like
you know i was like wow that'll take me
like quite a while to read not really
because i read pretty fast but um
it's the longest one that i've reviewed
on the show so far but it did not take
me that long to read it
whatsoever just because it was so
engaging and it was so fun and it was
just so
i mean i like whodunits it's not like my
main genre i haven't read a shit-ton of
them like i've read some agatha christie
i've read some sherlock holmes i've read
some of the older stuff
and i do like some of those british
style whodunits like you need it on tv
and everything
which this kind of resembles in part
which is not surprising because anthony
horowitz uh
wrote midsummer murders or he um you
know created midsummer murders
and that's uh his main thing is writing
whodunits for tv
but it's just the the way that
this plays with the genre in a way
that's
not it's not making fun of the genre
it's like it's an affectionate love
letter to the genre but it does
something different with it
like in the way that you just have this
kind of old school one in a news and
they're kind of like bouncing off each
other and they're parallel with each
other
and i really really like the way that
was done this is definitely one book
that that i will probably need to reread
at some point because
i feel like there were so many clues in
there that i missed out on
you know what i mean and when when it
comes to the end and you figure out
you know who who done it you know when
you figure that out at the end
it does it is very satisfying and
everything makes sense and like
then you remember oh yeah he said this
and this happened with this so
everything does make sense
and he really did seem to take great
pains to like construct it in such a way
that
that the clues all add up that there
were so many people that could have done
it
but when you get to the end you're like
oh that's the only possible way it could
have happened
so it's like really really well done in
that way the only thing that i will
and this is not a criticism for my part
because this did not really bother me
but if you don't know going in
that it's essentially like a fictional
murder
inside a real murder like in the
universe of the book
so when you so you spent like 200 pages
getting really involved in this old like
murder that took place in the 1950s like
in the manuscript
and then to have it stop like right
before the end like right before the
killer is
revealed and then there's all this other
stuff you know because
you know there's like still half of the
book left to go so if you're not sure
that that's what you're getting into
then it can seem kind of jarring because
you'll get to the end you'll be like oh
[ __ ]
you know what i mean now now what but in
a way i liked that because it paralleled
you know the narrator susan ryland the
editor it paralleled her experience i
mean she got this manuscript she's
reading it over the weekend she's like
you know this is going to be our next
big book
and then the last few chapters are gone
and she's like oh [ __ ] now what do i do
so now she has to like
take up the mantle i guess and let go
and you know you do get to
they wouldn't leave you hanging like he
wouldn't leave you hanging like that
because i'm sitting there he's not gonna
leave it hanging is he like not
resolve the mystery or they're never
gonna find the pages or anything i mean
you do find out like what happens and
everything
but like i said everything ties up very
nicely everything is
very very well paralleled like between
the fictional novel and the real one
and it's just really really well done i
can see why
this was such a bestseller why it was on
so many
uh best books lists of uh 2017
and i can definitely see why it's going
to be paid into a series i don't know
when that's going to be out
the article that i saw was from july
21st of 2020
and they had just come out and announced
that they were going to do a six-part
series based on this book
which i'm sure will be really
entertaining because the book was like
really really entertaining
so if you really if you love murder
mysteries even new ones old ones
whatever this kind of has something for
everybody
and it's just so cleverly done and it's
just really fun it's a
fun read it's not super heavy it's not
super gory it's not graphic too much
or anything like that it's like a
classic mystery and a modern mystery
like all wrapped up in one so it's just
like
i really really enjoyed it and um so i
would definitely
recommend it if that sounds like
something that you would like
and so that'll do it for this review and
i'll see on the next one
bye